who won a very nice game thank you
alejandro we are indeed here with the
rating favorite of group number b robert
hungaski robert first of all welcome to
the studio and congratulations on this
bounce back how does it feel feels good
after yesterday's game i wasn't sure i
was going to get you know a chance to
come up here and
you know show a win or something it was
terrible
you started off with two whites and you
definitely delivered in this game how
does it feel first of all to be back
over the board chess to playing
overnight it feels great actually um
i've been playing non-stop since things
started to get more or less back to
normal like in november the tournaments
just started popping up again so i've
just been you know hitting it pretty
hard you're a globetrotter where are you
playing huh what are you usually playing
um well right now i'm living in buenos
aires so
i usually have my tournament circuit in
south america i just played some
tournaments in uh well buenos aires
brazil uruguay
cool well let's look at uh today's game
we're going to see that on the screen
right there all right
yeah
so through some of the key moments uh we
had quite the unusual opening but it
seemed i particularly wanted to get to
this complicated position
where it seemed like both of you had
weak kinks and it was very difficult for
us to fully assess the position
yeah it was pretty hard for me too
[Laughter]
um yeah i don't know about this g4 move
i mean i went into this line uh thinking
i could i could do g4
maybe something like b3 first and if a5
then g4 this could be a you know an
option because um
um maybe it buys me a little bit of time
but i know it looks scary you know just
creating that hook on b3 right um knight
c5 is coming too but i don't know he's
got to deal with f5 too so um
and i was a little bit impulsive maybe i
didn't pay enough attention to this
possibility interesting so i just went
g4
yeah
and um
yeah at this point things uh were a
little bit i started to realize things
were a little bit more uh
tricky than i first thought
for example if i had gone f takes g4
instead of knight takes
he has this annoying queen f4 move again
and
this pin is very annoying and if i do
something like queen d2
whenever i eventually kick the queen out
it's going to swing over to a4 and all
of a sudden i'm the one under attack so
knight of c5 right now yeah knight c5 is
coming queen a4 it just looks like
black's attack is is flowing a lot
easier than mine
yeah this certainly looks very dangerous
for you yeah and and this attacking
pattern of you know bishop on e6 knight
c5 and queen on on a4
something that's going to happen later
in the game
that's right we did see it after knight
takes g4 queen f4 check rook d2 e4 was
played
yeah and after bishop g3 queen g5 it
does it wasn't quite a four but it does
also allow the queen to transfer over to
the queen's right yeah kind of a similar
idea so yeah maybe this h4
i don't know um it just seems to help
his queen you know swing over
to the queen side maybe i should just go
on queen takes e4
but that also looks kind of sketchy
after bishop to f5
well knight to c5 knight c5 was was
something i was i was worried about
i'm worried about every movie
yeah yeah so i was kind of uh
disappointed you know i thought i was
going to be the one attacking and all of
a sudden it get turned turned around on
me
but you handled it very well after h4
you first played this really nice move i
liked it it the bishop on e2 not a very
valuable piece in your arsenal at the
moment and it allows your rook to come
to d7 and now again a double edged
position in which both sides are
attacking yeah basically i was like i've
had enough of this knight coming to c5
i'm just going to get rid of it besides
we're very low on time
at this point yeah five minutes for you
i don't know if bishop c4 might be the
only move there because there were there
were a lot of moves i was looking at
they all looked terrible for me yeah and
um here
i was very surprised he played queen f5
i think this is a bad move
uh i was expecting rook f7 immediately
trying to exchange this rook yeah um
because i'm threatening rook takes g7
followed by uh oh sorry uh yeah so i
think it's like some bishop e5 ideas and
queen e4
it looks scary yeah
um
the game starts to take an interesting
turn here because
uh this theme of the opposite color
bishops starts to you know become
important right um
and actually if he had gone rogue f7
maybe you guys can can help me figure
out what's going on here because
i was looking at rook takes
bishop takes
f takes e4 and after queen takes a2
bishop
and um
here i think he has to go queen a1
and he's probably going to be a
troishanki right i don't know queen b1
takes king takes and he has this bishop
g6 move
oh yeah
i missed that move
and um i think that's the position of
the rook to g1
rook g1 i think he just takes and then
takes on e5 that's just going to be a
pawn up yeah and goes king h7 i don't
think i have any good discoveries there
yeah i agree um so i was looking
i mean
i was talking a little bit with my
opponent after the game i think i have
to go like rookie one there after bishop
g6 yeah
but then i think he can just go a rookie
eight i like rookie eight it's a yeah
because you're gonna drill on e4 it's
gonna be well maybe you can go knight to
f6
here sorry no but even if you just go
king takes right and i go would i have
to go knight f2 that looks very sad no
knight f6 before after rook to e8 you
just tried to get into some sort of a
opposite or bishop yeah that that's
probably my my best bet yeah but he
wasn't looking he wasn't looking for a
draw he was trying to win just a second
can you go king to h8 or even king to f8
right now here yeah oh oh and trap the
knight no king to f8 yeah yeah i like
this one better uh knight takes and the
point is that after bishop takes e5
actually the knight is trapped nice very
nice
i like this variation a lot yeah perhaps
uh the rook f7
tempo was important and swinging the
queen to f5 actually another more that i
see it more it is a strange move because
the queen was so active on a5 i always
want to take on a2 he told me he missed
queen d2 and uh queen d2 is kind of a
game changer because now i'm definitely
threatening rook takes g7 oh my queen
takes h6 and all that stuff yeah but
still he had some chances
to survive and it seemed that his
decisive mistake came even a little
later
uh
here in this position did you consider
the move f2 immediately
um
i don't think so i mean i think i had
like 30 seconds here all right
yeah i was like i don't know i'm
threatening rook g1 and bishop d4
and it looks like a a really unpleasant
position for black i mean his king is so
open
yes we thought that f2 just basically
forces a transition into the end game
after queen to d4 because right because
if bishop takes now you have this check
on f4 right yeah
that's very important yes wow okay you
know i missed that
yeah we thought either queen d4 queen g5
could be up a pawn with
i'm not really sure how big of winning
chances and i can't do something like
nah i'm going to lose if i go like rook
f1 probably yeah rook f8 right yeah we
have rook fade and then queen e2 if you
don't trade the queens yeah okay
right yeah so so i have to go like queen
g5 you were saying or queen definitely
yeah
but i thought queen d4 take on d4 take
take and rook e8
and then try to swing the rook on the
second round king d2 bishop g4 right
something like that right yeah far far
from clear if black has quite enough may
have probably have to survive the end
game
but
much better than what happened in the
game of course after rook fade queen e5
it is lights out the f2 resource doesn't
really do nearly as much because of the
check a nice bounce back there for you
robert and
i mean it's been incredible to see you
play around the world that certainly
followed that tournament in montevideo
and it feels like your rating keeps
going up and up and up yeah we'll see uh
hopefully it'll keep you know i'll keep
the winning streak going well certainly
it is done today as uh you bounce back
to one out of two congratulations on
your win and good luck in the rest of
the tournament great thank you